bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france
expliquez-nous comment est-ce que vous
en êtes arrivé à cette estimation
comment cette étude at elle été menée
alors en fait une étude qui porte sur
les centres unis cancer qui rassemble
1800 sur le caractère national et
environ 25% des patients traités pour
cancer sur notre pays de manière
annuelle
nous avons corrigé l'ensemble des des
nouveaux cas de patients diagnostiqués
sur les sept premiers mois de l'année
2020 et comparé à l'année 2019 et
contrairement à ce que nous avions
observé au cours des années précédentes
nous avons cette année une diminution du
nombre de nouveaux cas pris en charge
dans nos établissements 7 % de
diminution avec un pic de diminution au
mois d'avril et au mois de mai avec de
manière assez surprenante une absence de
rattrapage sur les mois de juin juillet
qui sont les deux derniers mois de
l'étude
alors cette diminution a des
conséquences parce que pour le coup elle
entraîne un retard de prise en charge de
diagnostic et de traitement et on sait
que les retards de prise en charge sont
associés avec un excès significatif de
décès pour un certain nombre de
pathologies
mais reste que les patients sont
réticents à consulter ou bien il n'y a
pas essai de soignants ou d'hôpitaux
disponibles pour la prise en charge
alors en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que dans les mesures que nous avons fait
sur les centres encore une fois une et
cancer le les patients connu
précédemment était ont été au
rendez-vous en fait ils sont tous
revenus et l'augmentation de l'activité
habituelle a été vu pour les patients
qui étaient diagnostiqués précédemment
le vrai problème ce sont les patients
qui ne se savait porteur de cancer et
qui ont hésité à contacter leur médecin
généraliste les centres hospitaliers de
proximité où les spécialistes de
proximité pour effectuer les diagnostics
c'est probablement cet élément-là qui a
fait qui a entraîné ce retard de
diagnostic pendant cette période et les
raisons sont probables au mixte à la
fois le passé antique qui est la crainte
de venir dans un centre hospitalier où
où la crainte de transmission du coup
vite pouvait être importante à l'époque
et puis d'autre part parfois un certain
nombre de deux cabinets ou de structures
ont dû déprogrammer des examens
radiologiques ou des endoscopies tout
simplement parce que les le personnel
était mobilisée sur d'autres tâches à
cette période d'urgence
il reste qu'on peut ratera
mais ce retard de prise en charge alors
on ne voit pas de rattrapage sur ses
sept premiers mois mais notre analyse
s'interrompt au mois de juillet dernier
et effectivement les cinq derniers mois
vont être vont être cruciaux et on voit
actuellement une situation probablement
un peu différente sur nos centres la
situation étant que globalement le
nombre de nouveaux cas semble assez
similaires à ceux de l'année 2019 et que
donc les activités précédentes sur les
mois d'août septembre octobre et
novembre va devoir avoir rattrapé ces
patients qui étaient un petit peu en
retard au début d'année et ça c'est des
chiffres que l'on aura d'ici quelques
mois et alors qu'en est il de la
recherche pour les traitements contre le
cancer est ce que les laboratoires eux
aussi ont été mobilisés pour tenter de
trouver un remède au kobe 19 et donc du
coup au détriment d'un au détriment d'un
très bon contre le cancer alors la
recherche clinique a connu les mêmes
difficultés que l'activité hospitalière
d'une manière générale et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu pendant les périodes de
confinement un peu moins de
participation au protocole de recherche
clinique dédiée à la prise en charge des
basses atteints de cancer tout
simplement parce que toute l'attention
était portée sur la prise en charge de
routine ceci étant dit un certain nombre
de deux protocoles ont aussi été
développé spécifiquement pour les
patients atteints de cancer et
présentant une maladie qu vide qui sont
qui sont actuellement en cours de
déroulement et d'inclusion et d'autre
part je dirais que l'activité de
recherche actuellement est revenu à son
niveau habituel en terme de proposer aux
propositions aux patients de participer
et de nouveaux protocoles qui sont
générés votre étude ne prend en compte
que la première vague de l'épidémie est
ce que vous craignez les mêmes
conséquences pour la deuxième vague
alors la deuxième vague semble un peu
différente
il y à un peu moins de patients
proportionnellement que précédemment
parce que les démesures globalement
fonctionne de protection fonctionne bien
et les patients cancéreux sont
particulièrement attentifs à cette
protection
il ya eu un peu plus de soignants mais
c'est avec des contaminations intra
intrafamiliales globalement l'accueil
dès l'accueil des nouveaux patients
semblent moins impactées dans nos
centres en tout cas que dans l'est lors
de la première vague
ceci étant dit lorsqu'on regarde le
les chiffres nationaux qui sont qui sont
des chiffres publics les chiffres qui
sont observés en termes de réduction de
nouveaux cas diagnostiqués sur sur les
centres de lutte contre le cancer sont
probablement un peu optimiste par
rapport à ce qu'il ya observé dans
d'autres dans d'autres centres et les
chiffres globaux sur cette même période
actuellement disponibles montrent plutôt
une diminution de 23% du nombre de
nouveaux diagnostics plutôt que cette
diminution de 7% que j'évoquais merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions jean yves mulet
je rappelle que vous êtes président
d'uni cancer professeur de cancérologie